monsieur le juge en chef bonsoir
bienvenue à 24,6 au juge en chef de la
cour suprême du canada un des trois
juges du québec
vos décisions influence la vie des gens
dans ce cas le plus important depuis
fondamental c'est le socle de notre
démocratie vous l'avais dit à maintes
reprises depuis que vous êtes juge dans
votre discours d'investiture d'ailleurs
la fierté que vous aviez vous avez voulu
rappeler l'importance justement que la
confiance dans le système de justice qui
est véhiculé beaucoup par la cour
suprême doit être important pour moi
c'est fondamental c'est pour le mental
quand les genres calleja perdront
confiance d'un système de justice à
votre le début de la fin selon moi et
donc il faut être très soucieux de
maintenir cette crédibilité des
tribunaux dans l'esprit des gens et
c'est à nous de le faire c'était bien
d'autres personnes également selon leur
juridiction mais la cour comme tel les
juges ont une responsabilité également
on sait que parce que vous êtes de
nouvelle génération nouvelle époque 2018
que vous voulez plus accessible plus
ouverts vous prenez la parole peut-être
plus souvent publiquement vous vous
avancez parfois avec vos propres mots se
pose sur des terrains décembre mais des
terrains peut-être nouveaux
il explorait pour un juge qui vit pas
nécessairement là sa côte d'ivoire vous
vivez dans votre société vous parlez des
médias vous voyez ce qui se passe autour
les temps ont changé les temps ont
changé alors les temps où un juge
pouvait simplement rendre sa décision et
n'oppose prenons aussi ou ne pas à faire
preuve de plus de transparence comme tel
séjour de sont révolus je pense que les
gens aujourd'hui avec l'internet les
gens demandent et doivent avoir
l'information
je pense qu'il appartient maintenant aux
tribunaux au juge de dire qu'ils sont qu
est ce qu ils font comment ils le font
et pourquoi ils le font et plus des gens
vont être informés plus il y aura de
crédibilité de confiance dans le système
parce que rien pire que l'ignorance dans
l'ignorance c'est la source des préjugés
par définition vous avez évoqué qu'on
vit dans une époque trouble dans le
monde entier vous avez parlé d'autres
pays qui sont dans les institutions
fondamentales sont attaqués
régulièrement et très souvent c'est les
premières actions qui sont attaqués
c'est celle de
justice alors les premières c'est
évidemment dans les régimes tyranniques
de ou des squats autoritaire qui sont
les premières victimes mais ce sont les
juges
ce sont les médias d'information ce sont
les avocats alors il faut toujours être
très très vigilant lorsqu'on s'aperçoit
de notre pays en question
en particulier on attaque c'est ces gens
là et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut être même au canada moi il me soit
à l'abri de cela ce moment si je pense
que oui je pense que oui il faut être
vigilant
oui aux vigiles on s'aperçoit que
maintenant il ya quarante pour cent de
la population canadienne qui prend leurs
nouvelles
en commençant par les médias sociaux ce
qui place le canada en deuxième place en
arrière de la corée du sud a autrefois
les tribunaux des juges la cour suprême
commentaires sur les médias
traditionnels pour véhiculer nos
décisions nos messages telle sorte que
la population des justiciables puissent
comprendre les tenants et aboutissants
comprendre leurs droits et l'étendue des
obligations maintenant ce n'est plus le
cas parce que les médias traditionnels
évidemment ne suffisent plus à la tâche
et les médias sociaux ont repris le de
20 ans pris en pleine voie traverse
diraient certains besoins de voies
parallèles et parfois dominante de vos
grandes préoccupations c'est l'accès à
la justice
plus du tiers des citoyens qui veulent
s'adresser à la cour suprême le fonds se
représente seul on a l'impression qu'on
a envie dans une société riche mais que
la justice et pour les riches seulement
pcistes c'est une menace sérieuse qu'il
faut prendre au sérieux
moi je pense que oui moi je trouve ça
inquiétant je pense qu'on devrait avoir
une bonne justice pour tous et non pas
une excellente justice pour certains et
danse à cela le fait que la cour suprême
monop 30 à 35% d'irak est persuadé bly
qui sont déposées par des gens qui se
représente seul c'est quand même assez
significatif et il faut tenir son avec
de conduire lombrics et la tâche aussi
parce qu'ils ont pas nécessairement une
connaissance du droit non on a décidé
effectivement décidé à la cour de les
accompagner tout que simplement de
s'asseoir sur les règles de pratique on
les accompagne
on les aide dans cette démarche là mais
cela demande évidemment des ressources
du stade sillonneraient vous avez déjà
déclaré que la justice est parent pauvre
dans notre société ça l'a été pendant
plusieurs années non seulement au québec
au canada mais également dans toutes les
sociétés où on à la règle de droit est
un système démocratique
on n'a pas investi dans le système de
justice et avec la radio ordonnant 2016
comme vous savez ça sonne et toute une
alarme et là les gens ont réalisé qu
effectivement il fallait investir
l'arrêt jordin je peux vous le rappeler
parce qu'en fait vous étiez dissidents
halliburton a plus tard pour nous et
pourquoi vous êtes là libre on serait
dans le jugement là parce qu'il y avait
un prix à payer quand un journal publie
un meurtrier libéré parce que vous
trouviez déraisonnable des procès
criminels qui est trouvait s'échelonner
ou des procédures devraient s'échelonner
sur cinq sets parfois dix ans je serai à
l'époque que le prix était cher pays
maintenant je me suis rallié vous poser
la question pourquoi je me suis garé
dans l'arc audi quelques motards en
raison du respect des précédents alors
l'arrêt jordin c'était l'arrêt
majoritaire même c'était 5 4 et donc en
vertu de notre droit il faut respecter
nos précédents et on peut pas
recommencer a changé nos précédents
quelques mots par la suite à laquelle je
me suis dit c'est le droit il faut le
respecter et on va fonctionner avec ce
mois est intéressant parce que comme on
ne peu de débat autour entourant la cour
suprême on lit les jugements
on les respecte on les applique mais on
vit une époque trop vous lisiez mauvais
l'époque trouve aussi à côté où il ya un
débat incroyable entourant la nomination
d'un juge de la cour suprême le juge
kavanagh c'est tellement pour être
polarisé politiser un processus de
nomination qui déchire les partis
politiques
on est à l'abri de ça ici mais est-ce
que vous quoi être cette histoire-là pu
avoir un impact dans la perception qu'on
peut avoir des trucs d'abord voyons donc
scellé justice est politisé c'est parce
que pas du tout même processus de
nomination pour ne jamais sinon j'espère
qu'on leur jamais
honnêtement je pense qui est possible de
penser qu'il est que cette cette
situation là vraiment déplorable
aujourd'hui je pomme m'allonger sur ce
sujet là mais pour quiconque est
soucieux de la règle de droit la
primauté du droit d' indépendance
judiciaire
de la transparence du respect des
institutions ce qu'on a vu récemment
dans les derniers mois est inquiétant et
désolant et je pense qu' il serait
erroné de se dire simplement le chili
nous au québec au canada ça peut pas
arriver donc on a rien à faire non je
pense qu'il faut être vigilant
il faut dénoncer ce que l'on perçoit
comme étant des attaques sur ses valeurs
fondamentales et restez à l'écouté faire
la promotion de nos valeurs c'est comme
ça qu'il faut réagir selon moi dans les
valeurs que vous avez défendu depuis
votre arrivée comme juge en chef parce
que vous avez réitérer un peu comme juge
en chef c'est la diversité canadienne la
protection du droit des minorités mais
aussi la protection de l'ensemble des
canadiens et c'est donc dire que vous
êtes à l'écouté delà de ce qui bouge
dans la société est ce que la question
est ce que c'est la société qui fait
bouger les tribunaux aussi les tribunaux
qui est en avance sur la société
en fait c'est la perfection ou l'autre
des des hypothèses je pense que les
tribunaux doivent quand même réagir et
et on l'a vu d'ailleurs aussi comme par
exemple dossier de correcteurs son aide
au suicide
est ce que c'est la cour l'addition de
la cour qui a influencé l'évolution de
la société ou si la société qui a fait
en sorte que l'aco est arrivé à ce
résultat de jeu parce que il sert à rien
vraiment de chercher la réponse soit
simplement de dire que la société évolue
et que les tribunaux ne doivent pas être
insensible à cette réalité dans et donc
on doit accompagner l'évolution
technologique l'évolution également des
moeurs et à titre d'exemple dans les cra
maintenant où les gens prennent de leur
nouvelle des réseaux des réseaux sociaux
des médias sociaux
il nous appartient à nous de prendre des
mesures pour s'assurer que notre message
en eau décision passe on a aidé les
médias traditionnels à la cour suprême
on le fait beaucoup mais maintenant on
s'adresse aussi avec un compte facebook
un compte twitter avec notre maintenant
notre cause en bref est un résumé de nos
décisions en une page
qui permet aux citoyens des communes
king de kuyt de comprendre les enjeux
d'un dos aussi en particulier alors ce
sont tous des initiatives qui visent une
meilleure communication avec les
citoyens directement tout en appuyant
évidemment les médias d'information
traditionnels vous parlez aussi dans vos
discours différent de compassion il faut
faire preuve de compassion c'est pas une
notion juridique la compassion mais en
quoi ça ajoute à une façon de la justice
d'après vous en quoi c'est la justice
plus éclairés mais ça fait partie de nos
valeurs de la morale nouvelle ère de
société la compassion et le droit c'est
la traduction de valeur alors quand on
regarde ce soit en droit criminel ou en
droit civil et commercial
cette réduction de nos valeurs de
société une valeur morale je pense que
la compassion la générosité une
ouverture d'esprit fait partie de ces
valeurs là depuis plusieurs mois déjà
depuis un an maintenant il ya beaucoup
de critiques adressées à l'endroit du
système de justice parle pas de la cour
suprême et de l'encens de la justice
notamment à la faveur du mouvement mais
tous un jour après jour ce qu'on le dise
qu'on entend c'est de dire la justice
n'est pas à niveau
la justice ne sert pas bien les victimes
présumées ou alléguée de d'agression
sexuelle donc on va justement sur les
mains mais à ceux sous ce qui peut
appeler pour certains des risques
représenter des risques d'abus tribunal
populaire on se rend justice soi même
est ce que je peux vous donner sur ce
terrain d'après vous demandez ça vous
inquiète
si la raison pour laquelle ce qui
m'inquiète parce que les gens
s'éloignent des tribunaux je demeure
convaincu que au canada par rapport à
toute autre nation du monde
nous avons probablement l'une des
meilleures magistrature très bien
entraînés très bien formés avec une
belle éducation est très sensible aux
valeurs de la société donc étant
convaincu qu'on a une excellente
magistrature ça me désolait de voir les
citoyens se retirer du système de
justice et adopter un système parallèle
par exemple alors toutes les mesures les
initiatives que l'on doit prendre doit
avoir qu'un objectif de s'assurer que
les gens reviennent pour ceux qui sont
partis et ceux qui sont encore là qu'ils
soient encore qu'ils meurent
partisan du système de jeu vous avez lu
beaucoup à chaque fois qu'on prend à
boudy certains de vos textes encore une
fois quand on lit les journaux comme les
réseaux sociaux mais vous vous les
entendez quand vous écoutez la
télévision les gens il ya cette méfiance
là dedans la société alors oui invité
ces gens-là revenir mais comment le
faire
comment parce que ça commence pas par
les tribunaux ça commence par la police
ça commence par chacun a son rôle à
jouer chacun vous avez raison c'est ça
fait partie du cynisme peu de certaines
personnes la société alors qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire chaque corps de métier
chaque profession doit contribuer moi je
veux juste parler pour les juges les
vues doit faire preuve de transparence
qui n'est peut-être pas le caillou
peut-être quinze ou vingt ans 25 ballons
on doit faire preuve de transparence
alors qu' on est quand même on est nommé
pour qu'on les nommer comment fonctionne
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de rendre
jugement donc faire cet exercice là et
je suis convaincu que si nous faisons
cet exercice là et que les autres corps
de métier ou de professions font le leur
savoir faire en sorte qu'en bout de
ligne on va regarder les citoyens
dans le giron du système de justice où
sont passés trop lent et j'ai même
entendu je pense qu'après je peux
proposer le terrain politique pour mon
idée bien partis politiques qui suggère
de créer des tribunaux par elle est très
douce spécifiques comme des tribunaux
pour nous dans un tract pour les
victimes d'un meurtre
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un droit
différent pour ce genre de situation je
pense que c'est votre question est
hypothétique que dans la mesure où on
n'est pas rendu là je pense que notre
système de justice tel qu'il est composé
présentement lorsqu'il est bien utilisé
devrait normalement répondre à ces
besoins qui sont urgents aix maurienne
pour répondre aux besoins de répondre à
toutes les sphères d'activités si vous
avez on a parlé de vos priorités de
votre ce qu en terminant c'est trop bref
l'homme et qui s'étendra s'en prendre à
votre priorité comme juge en chef dont
la priorité c'est de m'assurer que l'on
communique convenablement et précisément
avec les justiciables donc rapproché la
cour
de la communauté et des citoyens pour ça
que l'événement qu'ils attendent en
quelques instants il aurait
effectivement un événement sur la carte
est recommandé gens par le biais des
clips bien fait et très clair langage
accessible peut effectivement favoriser
l'accès à la justice
eh bien monsieur le juge en chef
raisonnable merci beaucoup merci
d'avancé